nine fun details you missed in The Last
of Us episode 7. the pills found on the
dead body look a lot like the pills Joel
gave to the federal soldier in episode
1. the keys Captain Kwang show Ellie
have the Naughty Dog logo on them the
developer of The Last of Us games the
AHA and Etta James cassette tapes
contain songs that will later be
featured throughout the episode The
fictitious brand of whiskey they drink
Hamlin is named after a famous
prohibitionist at the movies we see a
poster for dawn of the wolf 2 a film we
see advertisements for in the game a
Mortal Kombat 2 poster can be found in
Ellie's room the same game she found at
the gas station in episode 3 and will
later play with Riley the name of the
mall is called Liberty Gardens ironic
since Boston is currently under
authoritarian rule in the game Ellie and
Riley never get the photos from the
photo booth the Macho Nacho where Riley
has her Hideout is a restaurant you can
actually find in the game for more fun
details check out think Story on YouTube